ans
le plan
autodidacte et les demandeurs donne
depuis 1971 beaucoup de son temps à son
quartier des hauts de sainte marie
touche à tout elle fait preuve de
beaucoup d'imagination dans plusieurs
domaines et met un point d'honneur à
transmettre ses connaissances et son
expérience de la vie aux membres de son
association
l'association s'appelle comment ben
l'association s'appelle l'association de
leur acheminement racheter nos ça veut
dire aura chez nous ça veut dire donc
c'est possible que j'ai pris à chaque
quartier en rance et à windhoek au 6e
chiendent et l'os et montesano comme il
ya des gens qui est montée saint lô qui
vient dans l'association et allégeant
leurs arts inc au quotidien et moi-même
j'habite à chiendent donc ceara chez
nous j'avais dit ça comme ça je dédie ce
poème à tous les gens qui habitent les
toits qu'anticipé en chine au donc ainsi
là pour chaque camp kg et nous fait pour
rester dans un ciel sans nuage
loin des embouteillages
montée saint lô situé bureau dominent le
paysage
au sommet d'été forêt
découvrez la beauté d'un reflet dans la
nuit et les villes et villages
par des deux gros bras du brc nous
piquent entier rabin que paul et linda
quand le temps est maussade que bonds de
l'orage théo dévalent les cascades au
plaisir des habitants de chiendent sous
un rayon de soleil les maires les
ramiers refoule 7 et goya qui
les payons que profite pour danser une
room au dessus du bassin brute au gré du
vent
les bambous courbe le dos de s'allier à
bingo et depuis combien d'années vous
avez repris l'association
bingerville à l'association
en 92 ça va faire bientôt dix ans c'est
une vitrine alors donc au pôle emploi
on y travaille on a beaucoup de dames
qui viennent donc on a fait une dame qui
a fait la vitrine donc on va venir la
danse et une inertie est actuellement
qu'est ce que vous faites
mais là on fait un peu de tout ou parce
que moi même on a débuté par
le tricot et puis bon y'a le rocher il
ya aussi la broderie il ya le bambou
c'était violent
vannerie donc il ya plusieurs plusieurs
ateliers donc vannerie bambou le bois
tableaux par charles bak points et puis
la culture et la peinture et puis aussi
d'être encore fait aussi un petit gâteau
apprendre à faire des gâteaux
traditionnels
maillots de bain de ces gâteaux titien
que des fois remis en cause il aida
médias de faire ce que l'on a remarqué
que le cerveau de l'homme les bras que
il réagit un petit peu comme un
chauffe-eau électrique donc moi comme
mes dieux
pour me transmettre mon savoir faire
et aussi rien ne dit que les transmettre
et la vida qui revient c'est un petit
peu le chauffe eau électrique c'est
quand on prend l'eau chaude il ya deux
ou trois ans ça veut dire que le charrua
toujours plein donc le cerveau en tout
cas me fais avoir moi elle est toujours
plein
est ce que ça ne vous manque pas sur le
call l'ajustement oui bien fait vraiment
beaucoup parce que étant donné que quand
on sort chez soi on vient de
l'association s'est pas rencontré
d'autres personnes
mais moi je suis obligée de rester tout
seul ici dans mon atelier tout dans mon
appétit dans ce soir ou jamais mais pour
moi ça me pose un problème parce que
l'association ses épaules épanouissement
humain n'est donc
les autres personnes bien deux schémas
d'accord mais moi aussi j'ai envie de
sortir de partir aussi et puis à part
que ça il ya aussi des jeux on faisait
aussi avant pétanque il y avait aussi
des jeux de scrabble roman je donne
encore l'occasion aux gens de venir
apprendre mais moi j'ai appris je dirai
tout seul un plusieurs travail j'ai
appris tout seul
d'autres par contre il ya ma belle fille
qui m'a appris on fait un échange d'acer
exemple par jour c'est ma belle fille
qui a pris ça dans une association en
métropole met donc les majors que c'est
à dire votre chance
duy
dans l'association est dit vous êtes
beaucoup la peinture c'est ça vous vous
créez
madania trophée la peinture d'accord je
viens d'avoir la notion de la peinture
oui parce que j'ai manqué ma vue baisse
ses obligés de porter des verres mais
pour la peinture c'est le contraire
ma vie augmente donc ça c'est mon
premier tableau que j'ai fait c'est le
premier tablet oui
donc ça j'ai vu c'est une copine mais vu
ça dans un bateau il est dit que c'était
vraiment un tableau qui est vraiment qui
a la vie dedans
et vos peintures voulait faire avec
quelle matière eh bien je fais avec la
gouache d'accord dès fois aquarelles oui
mais non j'ai un petit peu élevé
est-ce que vous dessinez d'abord vous
son gré du pinceau
ainsi the yards et 5 et un peu trop
difficile je suis obligé de dessiner oui
mais après je suis attiré par exemple
par les paysages par exemple le singe et
pas besoin de baisser les bras c'est
avec mon pinceau je fais essaye de faire
un arbre comme ça ouais ouais un rocher
bien
la mère de sa part de la dessiner sa wii
bien 16 ou en voiture et à mesure
globale un élan oies et ben voilà on va
mettre un peu plus loin plus foncée sait
si cela mais je suis pas un
professionnel quand elle arrive parler
des femmes quand elles arrivent est-ce
que elles arrivent elles connaissent
déjà faire
de l'artisanat ou bien j'arrive à les
apprennent ou y mais des fois il avait
il connaît rien et qui commencera brand
et moi je dis toujours aux personnes qui
viennent
quand vous venez de l'association c'est
pas un poids enrichiront vient pas de
l'association pour s'enrichir on vient
dans l'association pour économiser je
prends l'exemple d'un
d'une dame par exemple elle attend un
bébé et son mari travaille gagne par
exemple le smic avec toutes les chances
sociale donc souvent des fois c'est
difficile de terminer le mois donc et
elle va accoucher par exemple le dans
l'hiver est là il ya des elle est
vraiment intéressé par les trucs des
vêtements chauds donc elle va venir où
l'ue d'aller acheter elle va venir
apprendre à jeter les fils les églises
ou le crochet elle vient à prendre cette
association c'est l'association
d'éducation populaire d'accord donc on
reçoit en l'éducation un potage ou et
c'est facile d'éduquer des enfants et
les adultes c'est pas pour facile et il
faut vraiment se voir des fois utilisé
un petit peu la diplomatie
par exemple quand on voit un enfant qui
jette un papier de remporter on lui dit
ben coulter hamas tout mis à la poubelle
et si un adulte quand j'étais sa part a
t on va pas dire de la même façon ne
serait il pas les imiter un oui donc on
march essaye de voir ça
autrement comme ça et puis après veille
contre les compagnies qui fait
normalement vous êtes écoutez pas de
problème ça se passe bien pas de
problème je suis écouté mais j'apprends
beaucoup aussi avec un oui oui ça les
change où il va casser les changes mais
parce que moi aussi j'ai besoin aussi
d'être évité des tendances en un an
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent à votre mari
abelli content de compiler content parce
que maintenant j'ai un petit peu un peu
plus de temps aussi comme il est
retraité dont ils mettent beaucoup aussi
une raison pour le ménage tout ça et moi
j'ai suffisamment dans pour faire la
peinture avec les autres électrique le
jour si la hausse là
et ça c'est quoi va se réaliser ici ceci
moi même c'est moi même qui fait le jour
silence on trouve de tout ici dans
l'association de tous et la signer trois
mois il fait part des adultes
mais il faut que les parents donnent
l'exemple
parce que moi j'ai eu l'exemple de ma
maîtresse d'école quand j'étais petit
j'ai envoyé ma maîtresse d'école et côté
tous les récréations comme j'étais
timide je parlais pas avec la maîtresse
à lui dit déjà qu'on serait conférée
common et à l'école et je fais comptait
aussi des gens je dirais
exemplaire des dames qui s'est fait
hacker quelque chose quelque sorte je
fais compter ces gens là pour apprendre
justement mais moi je dis que et et des
fois par exemple j'ai pas envie tricot
bien quand j'étais par exemple dans les
locales soir à la montée bien
rallier au coeur des fois j'avais pas
envie tes côtés parce qu'il y avait au
moins 20 personnes pour leur apprendre à
faire le point le bruit baudis pourquoi
bon mais n'empêche que avant de
commencer j'avais toujours mon ouvrage à
la main ça parce que je sais comme moi
j'étais comme ça quand j'étais petit je
suis sûr qu'il ya aussi d'autres enfants
sont timides comme moi ils vont vraiment
aurait gardé ce que je fais et quand ils
vont féroce il faut motiver les enfants
il faut que les parents donnent
l'exemple